when you
walk me through like what it would be
like like a day in the life of a police
officer
in the area that you were working and
like a day not in just any police
officer's life but your life like how
what was like the percentage of crime
organized crime you were participating
in and like the percentage of actual
police work you were doing
okay so i guess there's two different
ways to describe it so
there were times when i was just as an
ordinary patrolman which is what i was
most of my career
um i would have two different i had two
different approaches in the beginning i
was like a glutton you know i would uh
every job that came over as a drug run i
would go on it
and it was a 50 of them a day you know
so you'd call them 50 different drug
calls a day
so not everyone did you rob at because
you know these guys had slipped too they
tried to get robbed you know and then
sometimes you would take it or
because so here's the deal the police
department didn't want you making drug
arrests okay
so start with that so now you're a
police officer
in a crack infested neighborhood and
you're getting called
to 30 40 50 drug runs a day if you're
not on one you're backing up on one you
know so whatever so the point
is and we backed each other up out there
pretty well because
any minute guns start flying and bullets
start flying out there and it was and
and
it was a violent neighborhood there was
violence every day i mean they probably
took we probably averaged five guns a
day
taken off the street in one precinct
alone maybe more all right
so and we averaged about a homicide
every day and a half
so and usually it takes ten
shootings to get one homicide you know
maybe eight to ten eight to ten
shootings is one homicide
so you're talking about 2500 shootings
in my precinct and
100 murders you know so in that ballpark
you
know
my numbers are up right now but in that
range how many how many people were you
arresting
none you were never you never arrested
anybody
i made 43 arrests in 10 years that's it
yeah i made twenty i made 36 of them in
one year
36 36 felony arrests in one year yeah
and then after that i was done and after
that for the rest of year for the
remaining nine years it was like ten
more
yeah maybe less i don't know yeah that's
wild
i was done i was i was apparent i done i
was you're getting trouble making
arrests
so i found out another way to make money
yeah making arrests was a big money
maker
you know every time you make an arrest
you usually get overtime right
so the cop goes for making at that time
i guess i was making well if i say
23 an hour i went up to making 36
dollars an hour
so and most of the rest work is
paperwork and drudge work but it's
you know paperwork it's court appearance
it's it's it's in the da's office it's
transporting a prisoner so you know now
your buddies by the end of this your
buddies you hate each other by the end
of this because
you're with this guy in the next 16
hours okay you and your prisoner really
you're hanging out for the next 16 hours
yeah
together so if you make an arrest you're
basically just looking around
your pal wow you went from [ __ ]
running somebody down
knocking about head to giving them a hug
and buying them a beer that seems like a
pain in the ass
seems like a waste of time why i mean
why does it come out that's how it was
i'm telling you how it was and that's
not necessarily that way but i'm hearing
i'm hearing today that it's sort of back
to that again really because the volume
of arrests and the
backlogs in the system and you know and
then
the no bail because the guys they don't
they don't post bail they're back out
and they get arrested some guys got
arrested seven times in three days in
three days you know i mean they back out
into
in four hours so i mean so from what i
understand it's really out of control
right now but i'm talking about
from my experience that's what it was so
an arrest equals money
so if you don't make arrests you know i
found other ways to make money
what was it like so the first time you
started working for there was the one
guy who worked
what we're overlooking is the fact that
the police department didn't want you
making drug arrests
and you became the armed security for
the drug dealers
make sense what do you mean why didn't
they want you making drug arrests
because of cost money
interesting they're only worried about
money it's a city
it's it's a municipal organization
they're worried about money
huh so every time i made a drug arrest
for a crack dealer or a marijuana dealer
at the time or heroin dealer at the time
i took myself off the street i made 17
hours overtime
i put one guy in front of a judge the
guy went in front of the judge he got
bailed out
you know for you know a day later and
cycle repeats itself
so at the end of at the end of the week
i could make i could have made five drug
arrests
every you know one a day because once
you once you make one you're off the
street
you get it right so they only make the
arrest at the end of shift because then
you get
overtime the whole the whole run okay so
what did they want you doing if they
didn't want you making drug arrests just
be visible
just to be visible be visible so that
the homicides would stay down
and summonses okay and make sure you
write your book
summons yeah so i used to write him to
benjamin wood
he was the commissioner at the time and
when did all this change when did this i
mean
at some point there was a a huge
push to get everyone that was dealing
crack or
coke off the streets right yeah so um
so there was an error there was a time
when they executed a cop eddie burns
uh the drug organization in queens uh
executed a cop
uh by um he was guarding um a witness's
house
and i could be wrong in the year it was
either 86 or 88 i don't remember quite
but
so on the back of that
the pd and the feds teamed up and they
before the joint task force together and
went seriously after the
crack organizations in queens
specifically
it was it was odd though because they
actually went after the crack
organization in queens but not those in
brooklyn or manhattan or the bronx you
know
because because they executed this young
cop who was sitting there
caught in the uh witness um so that was
where the push came from
and what happened was the fed stepped in
and
there's new laws that they're all
complaining about that joe biden put in
place back in the 80s and 90s
those laws kicked in and the feds began
to
enjoin arrests by city pd
so the city pd and the federal the
federal uh offices worked together so
that they would take them from city
prisons to federal prisons so that began
to
i mean when i hit the federal prison
system in 92 there was 46 000 inmates
when i left in 2004 there was a 190 or
185 000 inmates so the population
like quadrupled while i was in the
system
and most of those people that came in
were young
black ghetto crack dealers
really yeah probably a hundred thousand
all arrested for
crack for a crack just for possession
was there anything like that no no no no
no listen listen no one in there is
there
no one's in there for the first failed
sailor crack okay right no one's in
there for that in fact they're not in
there for the tenth sailor crack what
they're in there for is crack and
violence
so they would say oh we gotta let them
all out
good luck you know i mean you know and
i'm not saying everyone don't
i'm just giving you a blanket example
you know and then there's guys in there
that sold one kilo of crack
to one undercover and they got life you
know 22 years old they got life you know
right
set up you know never saw the kilo in
his life you know but i
they gave him a kilo to sell to you wait
a minute
this is both defense on both sides here
that's anywhere yeah entrapment right
it doesn't work in a drug case that's so
[ __ ] up yeah
yeah it's crazy that you at such a young
age were able to
i mean develop that that street
mentality
to be able to co-exist with these guys
and work with them and make money with
them and
like even how uh the one guy that that
runs the cigar
the rosa cigars who was talking about
you he was like yeah i could talk to
this guy and he was just like me
like is that a compliment i could
recognize i don't know if that's a
compliment yeah well like
he's a street guy he's a new york guy i
can talk with him i can
i can you know hustle bustle with him
and he's not like a normal cop
well it is i i think if if you show
vulnerability and
and i mean by that i mean you take risk
like like if you take risk
people accept you more right so
for me to have the balls to come up to
somebody and say you know like
i'll give you a funny example i was uh
working in 7-5 with my partner at the
time his name was jerry
we pulled this car over 280zx maroon
back then that was the hottest cars you
know there's maroon or burgundy colored
2a 280zx i pulled him over and i go to
torch the car
because i know he's that's their car and
i tossed the car i can't find it and
he's looking at me he's like sweating
his [ __ ] balls off i said that
all right you're good this time you know
and i let him go
and now i get transferred to coney
island remember i told you i transferred
to coney island
okay so i'm walking to beaten coney
island and this hispanic guy a little
short stocking guy says
hey batman and robin and i don't know
who the [ __ ] batman and robin are
it's me and my partner that's our
nickname to them right
so i go who's batman and robin he goes
well he's batman because he's taller
than me and you're robin i go
okay what's up he goes you guys are in
the wrong precinct
so oh you're really smart you know
because
cops take their numbers from their old
precinct and put it on their gun belt
so if you see it back in the day you
take you you put your new numbers on
your shoulder so 6-0 precinct
because that's coney island and i put my
75 numbers on my gun belt
i said you saw my [ __ ] gun belt
numbers he goes no you pulled me over in
the 280zx i said burgundy he goes yeah
i said the back trunk he goes yeah you
because it was a hatchback
yeah he said you missed it there was 10
kilos in there
i said you [ __ ] he says all you
have to do is pull that [ __ ]
the uh the mold there's a there's a like
a plastic mold or a
that gives like a cardboard mold off to
the wheel well
he said it was in the wheel well i said
you [ __ ] jesus but when you come
back to the 7-5
i got something for you oh yeah what do
you mean by that
like like i want to work with you oh
yeah yeah
he says i said i said i said why he said
because you never try to lock nobody up
you just want some money
somebody said you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you got me right
he said we used to call the police we
used to call 9-1-1
to see who shows up and when you and
your partner were working we knew we
were good for the night
this is how [ __ ] criminals work right
they would check on themselves and see
who's gonna roll up
so anyway so yeah that was that's so
that's what it's like
i